[Music]
today's question comes from mike in
texas he says my wife and i are debt
free except our mortgage and a 401k loan
that we use to pay off consumer debt we
desperately want to move out uh but we
apparently missed the best time to sell
our home it's a beautiful house on a big
corner lot since interest rates went up
dramatically our home just sits on the
market we've dropped our asking price as
low as we can do we need to be patient
with the current housing market or take
it off the market and try again next
year
good question from mike
so it's it was an amazing time it's
still a good time
to sell the home so there may be other
factors here dave that we don't know
about about this home sitting on the
market
yeah that's probably true we don't know
how long it's been sitting either he
hasn't said yeah i mean i i have met
people who put their house on the market
and two weeks later are panicking
because it hasn't sold that's the
question has it been two weeks or it's
been four months or is the difference or
has it been four years i don't know i
mean
i missed it i missed the one chance
no
you didn't um so here's the thing
i don't know if you have an unrealistic
view of what the house is worth
uh we've taken it as low as we can what
does that mean
okay so here's what i would do um
number one the housing market we just
talked about that a second ago has
slowed down
and sellers are experiencing a more
normal process
for 50 years
with the exception of a two-year period
of time that we recently came through
the normal days on the market for a
house selling was somewhere in the 60 to
120 day range
you know two to four months
that was a normal time to sell a house
i mean and there's been times it was a
little bit slower and times it was a
little bit faster
but in general that's what it was and
then we went through this two year
period of time where after covid people
came out of their caves looking for
houses like baptist after a casserole
they were going nuts
and they drove these you know house was
on the market for 32 minutes and had 87
offers
and that's spoiled everybody rotten so
here's the deal we're back to a normal
market it's a 90
to 120 day days on the market dom period
that we're sitting in and you have to
have the house completely merchandised
and staged and ready to go you need to
clean the freaking bushes at the front
yard so when you're standing in the
street it doesn't look like trash lives
there curb appeal curb appeal bubba you
know and you got to clean up the dadgum
and you got to get the cat has to go
visit somewhere else because nobody buys
a house with a dadgum cat in it and so
on right and and so you can't just put
any old piece of trash on the market and
sell instantly anymore so i don't know
if you've got those kinds of problems
the other problem you may have is an
unrealistic view of what the price is
see values have not come down
prices have
because prices were many times someone
fishing for
uh a sucker
a sucker fish
and they were looking for a sucker and
the price you price it at sucker price
and go if sells for that i'll be a happy
boy you know and but then you come down
you recently bought a property where a
guy was fishing for suckerfish oh yeah
and you made him an offer complete with
all the data that says the appraisal is
worth less than you are asking and you
didn't steal the house but you got it at
appraisal yes when you look at the comps
in the neighborhood and go what have
homes actually closed for in the last 30
or 60 days that gives you a much better
idea of what this home is actually worth
do not go to zillow and go well my house
is worth 850 000 according to zero days
oh god so it should sell for 850 because
zillow said so
zillow is not just no you remember the
old map quest thing oh yeah which pretty
much was greek for guaranteed to be lost
zillow is the map quest of real estate
you heard it here first so yeah don't no
no i mean it's okay to look at it it's
it's do people still use map quests no i
mean old people are the only ones even
know about it so but
um i mean you know yeah the dial up
yeah and you print off the instructions
on the paper 14-4 right so um
anyway the the point being get a real
real estate agent and get a real value
and really stage the house put your feet
up
and get ready
to ride it out for 90 to 120 days
and if in that period of time you don't
sell it then something else is going on
okay
but i think you might have an
unrealistic view of how fast the market
is i think you might have an unrealistic
view of the value of your home versus
the price you put on it um
and the last thing is you're in texas
you could be sitting near some of the
areas that have been hammered
by the uh oil by the energy
world being turned upside down and a lot
of people aren't working and some of
those individual markets are actually
declining
uh it's not an it's not a nationwide
thing but you know you've got a mac a
microeconomic situation going on in that
community where a vast percentage vastly
large percentage of the buyers were
uh
in the oil business in one way or
another and now they're not buying
nothing because they got a job or they
don't have an income and so that can
cause a little miniature recession in a
certain area that can affect your house
price uh that could be a thing i don't
think that's what's going on here no i
think one of the other things we talked
about is what's going on i'd get an
opinion from one of our trusted real
estate agents and go hey look at this
thing what do you think what do you
think is going wrong here and it may be
time to switch real estate agents if
they're not doing a great job getting
some showings and offers you need to
have a realistic price with realistic
length of time expectations a high prof
high quality professional real estate go
to ramseysolutions.com click on elp for
ramsey trusted people
and
you've got a stage of the house and
actually market it and you know get it
ready to sell to the public which
generally has no imagination and so if
crap is all torn up in there they can't
see past it
and you won't sell the house that's how
houses have been marketed for 50 years
yeah and we talk a lot about this in our
real estate reality check event of what
is actually going on the market what is
it still a good time to buy is it still
a good time to sell and we show the
graph of the interest rates over time
and even though interest rates are going
up they're nowhere near what they were
back when you were selling real estate
no no not i mean even when i started
this show
they were they were in double digits
when we started the show 30 years ago
and now if we had double digit interest
rates i mean if we had if we had a 10
interest rate can you imagine the
whaling and gnashing of teeth
can you imagine but we were in 10
interest rate coming down from 18 so we
were calling that blast and you were
still selling houses at 18 interest rate
yeah not a bunch but they were selling
yeah yeah absolutely wow you were just a
great real estate agent yeah that's
right because i'm just that's because it
was at 22 years old i was a genius